en 2024 Denis aura 30 ans d'ancienneté
mais il sait ces jours à son poste
compter désormais directement menacé par
l'intelligence artificielle très fortes
chances pour qu'on finisse
comme c'est prévu genre éliminer lecteur
de presse internationale en silence il
réalise des revues de presse des
synthèse pour de grandes entreprises et
des administrations il ne voit pas
comment des ordinateurs pourraient
effectuer le même travail il faut quand
même relativiser un tout petit peu déjà
il y a des emplois qui ne seront pas
automatisables faut être clair
exactement où se faire couper les
cheveux avant qu'un algorithme y arrive
il y a un petit peu de temps les emplois
de bureau c'est vrai ils vont être plus
concernés alors il y a une étude très
intéressante de l'OIT l'Organisation
internationale du travail qui bosse
beaucoup sur ces sujets là et qui dit
qu'en fait il y a assez peu de métiers
qui vont être complètement supprimés
[Musique]
par rapport
et pourtant si je veux un prochain
100% de ses effectifs